if you're an investor and you're trying
to save for retirement you would put
about 50
into stocks and 50 into bonds but we're
in a very
dislocated story about fixed income now
i've taken my commercial real estate
position from 31
of my portfolio that's how big it used
to be i was yielding almost six percent
on that
for well over a decade i've reduced that
down to eight percent and i'm not
talking about residential right now i'm
talking about commercial
real estate
let me welcome to the show kevin o'leary
he has launched o'leary funds he has
launched o'leary fine wines he is the
founder of o'leary financial group
you know him from dragon's den you love
him from shark tank
he's also known as mr wonderful uh kevin
welcome to the show
great to be here thank you so much we
have so much to talk about and this
isn't our
this is more like a continuation of our
conversation because
for many years you and i have been back
and forth about where the best places
are to put your money and uh
now more than ever this is probably a
really interesting time to talk about
this subject
i think so and there's been a huge
change in the economy obviously coming
out of pandemic plus all the stimulus
it's caused some asset bubbles across a
wide range of asset classes
and that's why you have to go tiptoeing
through the tulips you got to be careful
at this point
okay so let's let's start talking about
you know what people should be doing
right now i mean things are
clearly changing we're coming out of a
very weird time
um there's a lot of money that's been
put into the market people are thinking
about inflation
people are worried about bubbles and
what what do you see on the horizon
well i think we're we're at a time when
we're going to go into an explosive
growth in the back end of this year
and in a way we haven't seen since the
1950s i'll give you an example
the estimates for growth in q4 go from
seven
to nine and a half percent you haven't
seen that for decades
and that's because of all this
tremendous stimulus at the same time
we've still got about nine million
people unemployed
so the fed is trying to keep their you
know pedal to the metal on keeping rates
practically zero so that these people
can be pulled into the economy
the challenge is that i don't think
really
no one knows the answer this yet is the
economy trying to bootstart again
2019 2020 doesn't exist anymore there's
been a massive digitization
in other words most companies including
big ones like nike if you look their
numbers just a couple of weeks ago
they've done something in five months
that they thought would take six years
they're
50 direct to consumer all around the
world
which has put a lot of pressure on
retail they don't need foot locker they
don't need that 1200 square foot
you know strip mall location they don't
need any of that stuff they're just
shipping direct to consumers
and that's across the board right
through the entire uh not only us but
global economy
and and that does change things a little
bit it displaces millions of people
you know the person that worked in a
restaurant the person that worked in an
airline counter the person that worked
you know in in returns for clothing
merchandise all that stuff is changing
incrementally a thousand here a thousand
there but in aggregate it's millions of
people
and the economy has to figure out where
they fit in the new digital economy
that's the challenge
well even even more so than the economy
itself is the individuals in the economy
i think everybody's looking at this and
you make a great point is you know
things have shifted in the last 12
months things that would normally take
12 to 20 years to happen have happened
in a short period of time
and now everyone's also had a minute to
kind of think about their
own situation their own career their own
personal life
and i hear more than ever that people
like well now what do i do
to capitalize on all this money coming
to the market
all of these changes where do i put the
money that i have where do i
invest and uh and how do i make sure
that
when all this money is exchanging hands
a piece of it ends up in my pocket
yeah it's a it's a great point i mean
let's just talk about the basics you
know
historically in an economy that was as
buoyant as this one
if you're an investor and you're trying
to save for retirement in the long run
you would put about 50 percent into
stocks and 50 into bonds but we're in a
very
dislocated story about fixed income now
because interest rates even a 10-year
bond 10-year bonds
still under 2 and that doesn't even beat
inflation so it's actually a negative
return after inflation
and so the place to be when you're going
through this adjustment because people
are making the assumption interest rates
are going to go up now because
maybe because of inflation maybe because
of hyper overactive economy in q4
and into next year all of these are
maybes nobody knows but certainly
it's risky because if you think about
people that want to retire down the road
you don't want to lose a lot of money
when the bond prices because rates go up
the pond the price of bond collapses if
you have a 10-year piece of paper you're
stuck under water
getting a negative return after
inflation for a decade that's a bad
outcome
so the trend now is to move more into
equity so instead of being 50 50 i've in
my own portfolio have gone to 70 30.
i favor companies that are very healthy
that are involved
in paying out distributions in the form
of profits and dividends
and that are in sectors they're not
going through some you know trump
dramatic change like
energy uh energy stocks are under
pressure
and they will be by the end of the year
i think because a lot of institutions
won't buy hydrocarbon anymore
it's kind of a strange outcome but it's
policy right down from the president on
down
but there's other sectors the economy
and what you want is to own a stock that
has pricing power and inflation
so they can actually increase the prices
of their goods and services
and indeed if you look back in history
inflationary times at least the
beginning of them
when it didn't go to hyperinflation but
maybe inflation two or three percent
you did very very well owning stocks and
big companies
that really had powerful balance sheets
so if you're putting 70 percent into
these equities because me personally i
have
zero in bonds like i i just there's no
point in investing in bonds to me it
doesn't get me out of bed in the morning
and get me excited um i'm looking for
bigger potential and you know i'm the
type of person i would if i'm putting a
hundred dollars into something
i would like to see it go to 200 or to
zero but anything in between
to me is just uh you know there's
there's better options out there
so i mean equities can't be the only
place what what
about real estate i got to bring it up i
mean we have a ton of real estate
investors that
have done extremely well this has this
has been the single
greatest performance of my real estate
portfolio in the 20 years that i've been
investing in real estate
i'm seeing 20 to 28 year-over-year
uh increases in in the value of my
portfolio and that
has you normally i project for three to
five percent
not 25 percent you're right it's been an
asset class i don't care what part of
the country you look at but let's let's
dig deep in real estate let's talk about
that for a second
because i've taken my commercial real
estate position from 31
of my portfolio that's how big it used
to be because i've held
you know climate-controlled storage
hotels
all kinds of commercial real estate for
for office space etc
retail office space for the for the
companies i invest in
all of that and that's been a huge part
of my portfolio and i was yielding
almost six percent on that for well over
a decade
i've reduced that down to eight percent
why i'm not talking about residential
right now i'm talking about commercial
real estate let's just go through that
let's start at the top
aaa office tower a place where i parked
lots of money for a long time
my office in boston and new york my
lawyers offices in those same cities
they're reducing their footprint by
about 30 percent
why because they've gone to a model now
where some large portion of their people
rotate in and out of working from home
not because they wanted to do that
not because they're worried about the
pandemic or when it's over or not over
et cetera
people over the last year have done
something they never would have tried it
would have been too risky they've
decided
because of health needs obviously during
a pandemic to try and work from home
24 hours a day and it worked we have the
technology to allow that to happen and
so so many and just
in my own companies i've got 10 000
people in my supply chain of just 26
investments
and what we've learned is people in
compliance accounting and logistics that
people used to work
in little cubicles they don't want to do
that anymore they want to work at home
and if we can't provide that optionality
to them
they're going to get a job somewhere
else so we've had to include that
so in every case for me where my
companies are headquartered
new york state florida texas california
that's the nexus of what i've got
we are slashing hacking chopping
litigating our way out of leases
all over the place that's not a healthy
backdrop
for commercial real estate i'm not the
only person doing it the whole s p
500 is doing it because we the new
normal is going to be some percentage
that work at home
that's not great here's another problem
office tower new york city
capacity of elevator 55 people
office 78th floor am i getting on that
elevator in november and december
not a chance in hell why would i ever do
that again i don't know it'll be covered
20 21 22
23 mutant derivative whatever it is no
interest in jamming myself into a packed
place like that
that cap rate as you well know in real
estate might have been 4.2 percent
prior to the pandemic my guess is and i
know everybody that owns these buildings
talks their book and they should
i bet you two years from another cap
rate on that aaa office in new york and
boston six percent so i'm getting out of
the way of that diesel train while it
gets repriced
let's talk about b you know second tier
real estate let's talk about uh
bed bath and beyond for example in b
grade malls all over america there were
1700 malls part of the pandemic
so bed bath and young they close 200
stores
why they don't need them direct to
consumer sales they curate bath oil
salts towels sheets everybody knows who
they are
but they've their online direct to
consumer sales are up 76
year-over-year so they closed all those
stores they walked away
what happens to them well nobody needs
them they've got to be converted into
climate-controlled storage cloud
kitchens
that conversion rate they're probably a
five cap prior i bet you they're trading
at a seven
plus they need millions of dollars to so
that whole space is a
mess in my view that is not a good place
to have money tied up we can talk about
residential next
yeah we'll talk about residential in a
second but i'm gonna unpack that a
little bit too because um
i i would say maybe 10 of my portfolio
is commercial
uh whereas you know the other 90 is
residential and multi-res
uh commercial but here's what i love
about everything that you said
is that you know cap rates have been so
low for so long it's been
almost impossible to generate positive
cash flow
in this space um and and now
seeing that it's a mess i love it when
there's a mess
i run towards it so i'm watching now
what's going on
and i'm saying you know we're probably
three to six months away
from uh you know a rugged ending to this
pandemic let's call it but like you said
who knows what's gonna happen next but
let's say in six months ninety percent
of of the country is vaccinated
um that's when the reality the wake-up
call will happen when these stores don't
have
a reason to open again that's when your
cap rates will go up and i'm
i'm positioning myself in a way to be
able to capitalize on these because i do
believe that these can be repurposed
i do believe in the the cloud kitchen
idea um
and i do think some of these office
towers yeah they you might not need an
office on the 78th floor but
you can convert a lot of that to
residential and uh and there's a ton of
value there right the cost of building
is a fortune
the cost of renovating is significantly
less um
and if we can you know i would say that
yeah there's there's a lot of
collateral damage to be done in the uh
commercial
real estate space but that's not a
reason to run away from it it's almost a
reason to run towards it i agree and i
think the way to look at it though it's
too early you're not even in the first
inning you're still warming up at the
plate
here's why you know let's talk about i
agree with you totally let's talk about
a city like boston the
huge demand for residential space at
least a third of the floors in these
aaa office towers are empty right now
and they're not they're not going to be
refilled so
you got to talk about the cap rate of
the overall building on a blended use
basis right
leases that come and are brought back
are renewable
a lot of people don't like to have mixed
residential in there so you're also
going to have to repurpose elevator
shafts
one side for residential maybe one for
commercial
then you've got to install hep filters
throughout the entire building
because people are going to be demanding
that let's call that a few million bucks
i mean there's so much capex you got to
push through so i think those things
instead of trading in a four cap
maybe a five maybe six maybe six and a
half cap that's the time to get in
and then or go through a fund that's
going to be on a stress situation
there'll be so many b
grade office that's going to be gutted
and turned into residential or some
other purpose cloud kitchen
or climate control storage all of that
stuff's going to trade in the seven to
eight cap
and that's the time to get a broad
portfolio so i'm
like you i'm sitting on cash i pulled it
out starting last january so i'm lucky
because i got a little pre-pandemic
sales then i didn't do as well getting
out in march april may but i was able to
get liquid on all of it except eight
percent and now i'm just waiting to get
back in but i think
i think he'd wait a year i think we'll
get the ten year back up to two and a
half percent three percent
cap rates are going to go through the
roof when that happens a few
bankruptcies please i love that
that really helps jolt the system when a
big tower goes to zero
and all of a sudden it's going through
litigation that's the time to get in
that cycle has been around forever it
used to happen every seven to ten years
we haven't had a good shot at this for a
decade plus
so 15 20 years since we had a really
good jolt
new york is bleeding red right now that
place is getting worse
with all the crazy politicians
everybody's moving here to miami
and then we can look at the residential
side which has been the best place to
have had your money over the last 24
months in pretty well any asset class
absolutely which hasn't always been the
uh you know the tune that you've sung
we've had
conversations about you know work you
were worried about a bubble
and interest rates flying high and you
know i've doubled down in
in residential over the last several
years um
you know no matter what people need
somewhere to live i always know that
piece
and the cap rates have been just
terrible
i'll tell you purchasing multi-family
buildings you know
your people are selling at a three cap i
sold a building at a 2.4 cap
about a month ago and i thought those
people were absolutely nuts to buy it
but
um you know that's what's what the
heck's going on here like how is this
to me i mean we've got probably another
year that we can sustain this kind of
growth and then we're going to hit a
wall like you can only go
so far before people can't buy anything
well it's very regional in that sense i
mean you look at in inner city san
francisco's not doing anywhere near as
well
as miami is as boston is i mean
austin texas i mean it really depends on
where you are
right now in miami if you've had you're
up about 40 percent
over the last 24 months on typical
residential the demand for housing here
is insatiable as people move out of the
heavy tax states like massachusetts
new york city uh other places california
we've got a lot of people displaced from
california
here the gut the mayor of miami has
really opened up they call him the
bitcoin mayor he's the digital mayor
he's really providing for companies to
move their staff hedge funds are moving
here
so it's been crazy and so now you're in
a really interesting place if you come
to miami and you want to buy
uh give you an example i watch uh the
indexes on condominiums
uh south beach i love to watch every
single building i'm
very well and i watch it aware of the
pricing over the last three years
every turn every time a condo changes
hands i get all the data and i store it
so i'll give you an example um
last year a three bedroom uh 2 800
square foot unit
the la with obstructed views uh against
the side building because if you go on
that particular building past the 17th
floor you get a full view of the city
and those traded in a huge premium but
this thing
last sold for three million one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in the
obstructed view 24 months ago it's on
the market today
for four million six hundred thousand
now it's got a real bid at 4.1 million
but they didn't close
but that gives you an idea and that's
right across the board that's a huge
capital appreciation
and of course maintenance fees on that
building are probably about seven to
nine thousand a month on top of that
i'm just picking one situation to give
you an idea of how extended those
markets are
and yet they couldn't rent that location
that
particular unit for any more than about
18 000 a month
you see how if you do the math that's a
really it's whacked out that doesn't
make sense
you'd rent in perpetuity if you could do
that deal that's absolutely
that's what i'm talking about yeah we're
doing i mean the in terms of rental
returns for me right now it's the
short-term
uh you know vacation market the right
what i call the recreational properties
that's where we have seen the biggest
bump uh i think
mainly because most vacations are now
domestic
um you know especially in the in in
ontario
toronto north of toronto i know you've
got real estate in the
in toronto and north of the city as do i
that has been possibly the best returns
i've had other than like
florida i've got naples and fort myers i
got two buildings that i'm involved with
the capstock caprese on which
we started in 2016 those will be
hopefully coming to market next year
if this market sustains we're gonna
we're gonna outperform
our expectations by a hundred percent so
i'm loving miami the same way you are
uh the short-term vacation rental market
which is probably a temporary thing but
tons of pressure here the rental rates
are through the roof we've doubled our
rents
since uh since two years ago and
everything is completely
completely full um everybody's buying
everybody wants to be buying there's no
inventory like where does this end for
me personally
i'd love to see it continue and i don't
mean to you know be
uh sound like a terrible person because
i know this is pricing a lot of people
out of the market
but you know if i've got if you've got
some money today
because people do have cash they've got
equity in their house they've got some
savings
um where where do you put your money
like where's
where's where are we going here yeah
let's take a hot city let we can do
austin we can do miami let's stick with
miami
um what's happening here now is you've
got the first stage of what i call
flat market and the way you can identify
flat market is
tons of of offers out there at extended
prices
back to that unit i talked about at a
4.6
ask last time it traded 3.1
multiple bids at about you know
sort of around the 4 million range so
giving a really good lift
but nothing closing so you've you can't
sell it at 4 6. people have figured out
including the rental they have to do to
it that they'd have to probably
wait three to five six seven years to
get their money back out
the market goes flat the amount
appreciation that's going to happen over
the next 12 months in miami
in my view if we mark to market the way
i'm indexing these buildings
i don't do you know single standalone
houses i index condos
that's a it's a very good way because
you get all the data and you can
understand it
region by region i don't see we're gonna
we're gonna get any
any appreciation for the next 24 months
zero
while the market waits out that bid-ask
illiquidity because usually what happens
is people will sit there
as long as 18 sometimes 24 months and if
they have to be a seller
then they'll start hitting the bids
which are going to be significantly less
and so you know then you start to see
the market either roll over or then you
have a stabilized price point but
if you're putting together right now if
you're going to buy 10 condos and rent
them out
i think you do a pretty you have a
pretty bad
outcome 36 months later which is pretty
far as you know three years that's all i
can really look at on the condo index
it's it's fully valued the chances
you're going to get another 40
increase in this over the next two years
zero
so i think you have to be cautious um
i think we are at a place where prices
go sideways for a while
not saying they collapse there's no
reason for that to happen with all this
free money coming from the sky
but price appreciation in real estate
you've got to be careful
there are so many cranes in the miami
skyline so many buildings coming in that
are not yet fully sold out
uh really interesting to see when this
puppy cracks because it hasn't cracked
now
in 12 years so i'm i'm not
i'm not ringing the bell i'm just saying
don't look for capital appreciation you
may want to look for other asset classes
at this point
well miami is a bit of a yo-yo city when
it comes to valuations
in 2008 i remember my properties
i only had two properties in uh in miami
and they dropped by more than any other
property values that i had
and then they rebounded by more than any
other properties that i had
and now during this pandemic miami seems
to be inflating more than any of the
other markets
so i do i do love it for that reason i
love a market that moves around a lot
because there's so much
opportunity uh to to make profit
but there are definitely some other like
in texas there's a ton of
spots in texas that i still think are
undervalued when you look at
sort of nationwide uh price points
and um you know across the board
there as long as there's cash flow which
if you can
if you can secure properties outside of
these core centers with cash flow
the returns are still phenomenal i mean
if you're talking about
housing prices and condo prices not
moving what do you think is going to
happen to equities i mean
you're a big fan of equities what's
gonna happen equities over the next
year or three years yeah but the thing
about equities one of the things
when when we leave real estate for a
moment here is there's a
people have to realize something about
it it is not a liquid asset
the cost of trading real estate the
transfer tax
issues the the appreciation versus
losses when the volatile pricing
it is not anywhere near as liquid as as
equities and so
you know you've got you have to pay all
of those costs let's call it five to six
percent of transaction
so you're giving up a significant
portion of the appreciation
and that's why it's not easy to flip
this stuff and so it's better to say
okay i'm going to go 33 percent of my
portfolio in real estate
it's a long term hold strategy so what
you said earlier really matters
when you enter the market really matters
because you could end up losing five or
six percent
three years later just the transactional
cost to get out if it's a volatile
market like new york and miami are now
volatile markets in terms of pricing at
all
different classes and sizes and strata
of price points
so i'm i'm i totally understand what
you're saying but i would be more
cautious in the entry point now
in big cities when it comes to uh you
know
every day i mark to market our
portfolios and equities i watch like a
hawk
and i use exchange-traded funds i like
indexing i like to say okay
i want to take an overweighting and
consumer i want to overweight healthcare
i want to overheat technology
i mean there's all kinds of etfs you can
do that with and they're totally liquid
they're in a tax wrapper they're very
efficient on tax basis
but that's how i'm doing it on the
equity side
so today for example um
i increased a position um i have a very
simple rule
i never let one stock become more than
five percent of the equity portfolio and
never let a sector like technology
become more than twenty percent
and so i'm constantly adjusting as
markets move up and down
tech slowed down for a while now it's
picking back up again so i'm constantly
adjusting using these etf wrappers to do
that
uh was trading this morning into um
into a spac um that i've i own many many
specs
before they do their deals i know all
the operators and so i was adjusting
some of the warrant holdings i have
i mean that's a very buoyant act of
liquid market it's completely different
than real estate
and yeah i'm very long right now because
i do not have another place to deploy
capital
there's not a whole thing not a lot of
things i like right now except the
liquidity
and the potential of appreciation of
seven or eight percent this year on
equities
yeah well i i'll tell you how i've had
uh it's been a let's call it since
uh late 2019 early 2020 before the
pandemic was declared since
that point till now um my equities are
up about 18
so they dropped now mind you right when
the pandemic hit they dropped like a
rock and i probably was down
18 to 20 percent that fully rebounded
and now i'm up uh as i said getting
close to 20
uh in a year and six months let's call
it a year and five months
uh real estate did kind of froze for a
bit
never went down other than the condo
market actually took a small hit for a
very short period of time but has fully
recovered
uh but the real estate portion is up
about 25
so in in an interesting year and i
always like to do this when i'm talking
to you because
it listen you you manage a lot of money
and a lot of your own money and a lot of
other people's money which i appreciate
you need to be balanced you need to
uh you know kind of hedge and diversify
and
you're into private markets and public
markets and and everything in between
um whereas i'm i heavy up in certain
categories i'll heavy up in real estate
then i'll heavy up and
you know i'd rather have 10 to 15 stocks
and each one represents five to ten
percent of my portfolio
um and then i just kind of focus on on
that category but here we are
we are the first time you and i had this
debate was in 2014. believe it or not
it's been a while since you and i have
been debating these things
and uh we got pretty heated about real
estate versus
equities and so far since then
real estate has outperformed my equities
every year not to say that it's
both aren't wonderful they can be
wonderful as are you mr wonderful
um but i i dare to look forward and and
try to give people advice who are who
are saying you know i've got
fifty thousand dollars they may not have
a million dollars but let's say someone
has fifty thousand dollars they're 25
years old
they've got 50 000 and they want to turn
that into something substantial
something significant how do they
how do they do that how do they take 25
000 and
turn it into something substantial well
i think if you're willing to
manage real estate in other words uh
buy a a a facility residential
put leverage on it by getting a
five-year maybe a fixed rate
and then rent it out and manage it i
have lots of friends that do that
particularly in student housing i've got
a friend who's in boston one of the
largest student housing builders with
construction financing and then he
stabilizes the buildings
that's been a pretty good return no
question about it then he's a long-term
landowner
in in you know cherished locations like
cambridge and things like that
but that's a full-time gig i mean that
that's that guy works
you know seven days a week 25 hours a
day
managing that and building his wealth
that way the other way to do it if you
have 25 000
most people make the mistake early on in
life in their early 20s not to put aside
something
and i mean the easiest way to do it is
to simply index it say i'm going to take
100 bucks a week
and stick it into the the stock market
which generally is given a
six and a half to nine percent return
over the last hundred years per year
with lots of volatility in between
but the long term over a career forty
fifty years you put a hundred bucks a
week aside even on an average salary
fifty six
thousand you're going to end up in a
good place you're gonna have like a
million and a half dollars
in your bank account forget about real
estate just using the stock market which
is very liquid and easy to do
you can't put a hundred dollars a week
into real estate and i always say when
people say well my real estate
portfolios beat my stock market outcome
i always say you have to do it liquid in
other words if you have to look at your
portfolio
turn it back to cash and then compare it
to what your cash value of stocks
are because they're totally liquid you
could cash them out by the end of the
day
not so easy to sell in a perfect time in
real estate
sometimes the market gets locked up as
you said earlier sometimes the fees of
exit are very high up to 10 percent so
i'm always cautious about that metric
but i have no problem with real estate
because we've just come off a 35-year
run where bond rates and interest rates
and cost of money
has gone to historic lows i think that's
changing now and that will be a bit of a
headwind for real estate down the road
but again it's which class of real
estate either stressed out real estate
and commercial or
tiptoeing through the tulips in
residential i have a lot of residential
real estate i hold
and you know you're right the canadian
markets toronto the
vacation areas you know georgian bay
muskoka these things are up
double over the last two years it's just
crazy what's going on there
but again i'm just wondering can that is
that sustainable my guess is not
but um i just think there's new asset
classes emerging
i think you know we haven't talked about
it yet but certainly have to position
yourself against inflation and recently
again going back to check the box on
regulators
the canadian the french the german the
british the australian
have all opened up made it easier to own
cryptocurrencies and it's just a matter
of time i think before the u.s regulator
provides the same
and that's been a very interesting place
to play i'm now three percent
in bitcoin five percent in gold and
really 22 percent
in fixed income because i took those
allocations out of my fixed income
portfolio
and they've more or less outperformed
the fixed income bitcoin has been
uh remarkable controversial um
but has a lot of interesting attributes
to it so
i'm i'm surprised that you're into
cryptocurrencies i didn't
i didn't expect to hear that from you so
you're a believer in the
cryptocurrencies then
you know i was very skeptical back uh
2017
because as you mentioned i'm involved in
lots of financial services companies
uh as an owner or you know um some of
some of my chair
and we are we're heavily regulated
heavily regulated
and in the initial um period
2017 when people really started to focus
on bitcoin and ethereum and
you know some other stable coins etc and
tokenized coins
which really got the regulator upset
they were sending out wells letters like
greeting cards
back in 2017. and if you got caught up
in that more
if you want whatever you want to call it
uh that was very expensive going through
the regulatory process to make sure you
were clear and you don't want
you never want to have to check the box
that you're under investigation so for
most
institutional players we did not
participate
for the reason of compliance now when
the canadian regulator a few months ago
at the canadian regulator which is a
very close ties to the the osc and the
amf in quebec
are very closely tied to the sec in the
u.s they share a lot of different policy
and so when they opened up i i came out
of the closet so to speak and declared
that i had been holding bitcoin since
2017 in a private wallet not in any of
my companies
uh but since then have have opened up
considerably and i want to tell the
backlash i got this is rather
interesting
uh when i you know i i i i declared the
three percent holding
on a you know very uh global
uh business cable operator
and watched by most sovereign funds and
pension plans in america and globally
and in europe within minutes of of
finishing that show
minutes i started getting texts and and
phone calls and emails from people
saying wait a minute
where did you get these coins these
bitcoins specifically i said
why does it matter they said 60
64 exactly because i know a lot more now
than i did a few months ago
are mined in china using coal
to burn coal to make electricity
in a country that is under sanction has
been accused of human rights abuses
and institutions were not happy
that that asset class which they
consider a property
was purchased from a non-compliant
geography now i'd never heard that
before
never and i had used or was
contemplating
balancing the three percent weighting
using the canadian etfs
i can't touch those etfs now they are
loaded with what are called
blood coin chinese coin coin
mined in an in an unsustainable way so
your
your sustainability committee is isn't
is a no then the ethics committees on
these large pension plans do not want
companies that are not compliant
with you know global mandates around
human rights and
and currently china's imprisoning
various ethnic groups
as you know are being accused of that i
cannot own
those coins so now i'm in a much
different place i have to invest
directly in minors that are compliant
i've i'm negotiating with dozens of them
now
and what i found when i moved to that
mandate where i'm mining my own coin
with its own providence
with its own it's their virgin coin that
only one owner me
i've got all kinds of institutions
calling me saying we'd like to do that
too
what's the game plan you need more
capital do you want to invest in more
miners which miners are you doing some
kind of compliance check yourself
i have a team hired now that that's
working for me that
is looking at every single compliant
minor in the united states
in norway in denmark in iceland in
northern canada
we are building out their facilities
we're going into partnerships with them
and how do they pay me back
royalties in bitcoin oh you love your
royalties
i love my royalties
[Laughter]
oh my god you know it's funny there's a
lot to unpack there
i do love that insight about the um
who knew right who knew that that this
problem was emerging in crypto land
but that's almost like uh that's a piece
of information that will help people
navigate where to invest in which
cryptocurrencies to invest in because
obviously the ethically compliant ones
are are much more um you know socially
acceptable and
and friendly so as the regulators kind
of look at these things that's something
that
needs to be taken into consideration if
you want to maintain your value in them
so
that is a great piece of information i
love that you're in that space because
it's not a space that i
would have predicted i would have seen
kevin o'leary into the you know three
three percent waiting i mean that
remember my rule i don't let anything
get past five percent as a single stock
the other thing i'm considering as a
proxy to capture the volatility of
bitcoin pricing
is simply owning the miners i mean if
you get a productive miner that is
profitable that knows how to do mining
ethically and sustainably
the value of that equity is going to in
my view trade with the same volatility
of btc
so i'm building a portfolio of miners
that i own and and so
and particularly miners many of them
keep their btc
on their balance sheet they simply mine
another coin it's sitting on the balance
sheet
so over time the value of that asset
trades in accordance
the whole company trades in accordance
with its ability to execute and
efficiently mine and of course the value
of their portfolio of btc
i think this is going to be a really
interesting market and it's a great
analogy to what you and i've been
talking about
i consider it a new form of real estate
it's not
a currency it's simply real estate and i
own these
very highly prized um coins with their
providence
and the knowledge that only i've owned
them and nothing to do with burning coal
to make them
as very valuable aaa real estate
it's that is some pretty good insight
and definitely a huge category that
people are asking a ton of questions
about i myself am
starting to play in that space i'm
aligned with you that it's
you know there's ways to hedge against
the individual coins themselves and i
think that's
definitely a strategy i'm interested in
but um
oh my gosh i just feel i'm just so
pumped about how much opportunity is
coming down the pipeline in the next
couple years
i'm with you on the optimism i think the
next few years are going to be
gangbusters in terms of the economy
opportunity this is a time where people
can completely change the trajectory of
their financial future if they make some
smart decisions
uh we will have to catch up again
because you and i could probably go on
for just about ever talking about how to
make money we
we both like money but we sometimes make
it in slightly different ways
i will i will follow up with this
because you said something that i knew
you were gonna say which
you you said if some if young individual
were to put a hundred dollars away
every month into equities or just into
the the markets themselves
the indexes uh they could save a million
dollars over the life of their career
which
i've done the math it's true and i've
heard you say this before so
i ran a little bit of math as well
because you can't just put a hundred
dollars a month into real estate but if
you could save up about 25
000 okay which is a goal for young
individuals
work hard save as much as you can borrow
it if you need to from somebody but
if you can put twenty five thousand
dollars as a five percent down payment
on a primary residence which is about
five hundred thousand dollars
and you were able to use it as both your
home and a rental property which is how
i got started
bought a house rented out all the rooms
and just break even
basically the rent just covers the cost
of financing the expenses
um maintenance insurance all of those
things
if you were to do that for 25 years and
the market were to increase by
5 a year which is a lot less than it has
over the last 20 years
um your your investment of 25 000
would grow to a value of 1.7 million
dollars
in that property over 25 years so
if you want to save one points if you
want to make 1.7 million dollars
you need a 25 000 investment and uh
you and i are both numbers the only
difference in your scenarios are using
leverage
not everybody wants to do that and
that's why you get the extra juice
leverage works for you when it works for
you and rates are low
if all of a sudden rates spike and
you're levered up
ouch it hurts so you got to remember
that that's the disagreement we can have
i have come to the conclusion that i
don't use leverage anywhere anymore do
not use it
don't have it in any portfolios i don't
owe anybody anything except for the
30-day float
on my credit card and i completely pay
off that balance do not want to be in
debt anywhere
and i think that's a good place to get
to in your you know late
30s if you can do that turn the tides
because most people borrow money
particularly in their homes
and on other forms of debt but at some
point in your life you have to turn that
tide and be a net saver and be
completely out of debt
nothing worse than arriving to 65
hundreds of thousand dollars in debt
that
really sucks yeah that that totally
sucks i i'm aligned with you but i
i also believe it's an evolution we you
know a lot of people are starting out
struggling the market's hard to get into
whether it's
it's stocks equities uh bonds real
estate
bitcoin uh it's you know it's hard to to
make a
a mark in these places without borrowing
money so i am
when you're young and you've got lots of
time to recover is best time to use
leverage
ideally in your 20s and in your 30s
you're using leverage not for consumer
spending but for investing
and yeah there's going to be a tipping
point maybe it's 40 years old at 40
years old
if you've done well and you've had a
good run and you've been smart you
should be able to pay off those debts
and self-finance
your investments moving forward which
would be ideal
um but it's it's it's a bit of both if
you like that video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe